and here we are at busch stadium a day
game the miami marlins the st louis
cardinals
johan oviedo gets the call today well
looking forward to watching johan oviedo
go to work today against this marlins
lineup last couple of outings for johan
he has been better
2-2
on the ground to shosha
and a 1-2-3 inning a couple of
groundouts in a flyout sandy alcantara
gets the ball on a wednesday afternoon
against the saint louis cardinals his
second start against them this year
part of his 14 starts thus far the 339
era again bloated because of that start
in la otherwise he's been fantastic
and that's a base hit the other way as
dylan may have broken his bat
and it drops into shallow left field
lead off hit
as goldschmidt set up 0-2
and he blows him away with a fastball
now sandy not backing off really going
after goldschmidt with velocity the
entire time
ground ball birdie there steps on the
bag and you know what that's what sandy
does well too roll double play balls it
gets him out of the first he's only 23
years old like still learning how to do
this at this level and he's still
growing as a pitcher and i think we've
seen it this year
and a strikeout on the inside corner
oviedo his first and that's six up in
six down he really looks like he is
pitching with conviction and purpose
this afternoon through an inning plus
it's a strikeout carpenter did not get a
piece of it went away
rolls it up the third base line that
stays fair and that's a base hit gets
down the line so well infield hit for
so-so
as the runner goes throw down to second
stolen base for soso
gets away on his way to third and that's
offline
and murder making things happen
put the pressure on good things might
end up happening certainly the case here
he has second base stolen but the throws
goes into center very aggressive pops up
quickly too that's awareness
two and two
and sandy comes back and strikes him out
a couple of k's in the second for sandy
he's got three in the score of this game
there's the strikeout and that's nine up
and nine down first time through the
lineup for johann oviedo with a couple
of strikeouts
that's a fair ball inside the third base
line by oviedo
it's off the sidewall and he stops it
first
and he may have had a double if he kept
going inside the top ten an innings
pitched
on the hole entering the start today and
should add more
to that tally as he gets the strikeout
there of carlson for route number two in
the third
as this one has popped up shallow center
jazz puts it away in three clean innings
four alcontera
here's a bounding ball to the shortstop
the young started to make a play and
then he thought uh better not
even try here because john birdie beat
it out and that's the marlins first hit
on the day and john birdie has just been
fantastic
runner goes
and birdie is going to keep on going a
base hit for sanchez birdie all the way
to third
and the marlins have runners on the
corners jesus sanchez with his first hit
of the season a little hit and run
action front foot down backside strong
good rotation here's an o2 pitch by
oviedo
and a ground ball play at the play a
strike by goldie the tag
keeps the marlins off the board and that
is out number two
birdie who as you mentioned moves really
well he's going contact right here
goldie sees it makes a great throw
and in a game like this again you're
facing sandy alcantra throws the ball
really well he's going to be tough
getting that out gunning him down
0-2 pitch and a strikeout
oviedo gets out of the jam
tyler o'neill trying to make it
22 straight
in reaching base
and 13 in the third against the starters
in this series no chance you wouldn't
think
no chance
tyler o'neal reaches with a base hit and
then that'll be an error the speed of
tyler o'neill that's 22 straight he has
reached base
o'neal to third
yachty back down contra
o'neal is hung up between
third and home throw to third he's back
in safely
they botched the rundown
and everyone is safe
and a ground ball is sandy gonna get out
of it he is once again rolls the double
play ball only needs to throw one more
pitch after the defensive miscue
oh two brinson pokes one into right
center field there's a base hit
and sierra a base hit
so said the second baseman trying to
keep brinson tight there at the back and
this could be two six
four the turn three in a double play
and with the pitcher coming up certainly
a chance to get out of this inning
oh uh-oh sandy gets hit on the left arm
unfortunately looks like he's all right
the one two
into de young he'll step on the bag out
of a jam again marlon strand a pair
they've left four on john bertie leaked
things off he's got one of the marlins
hits today
and birdie with a base hit in the left
field back-to-back innings where the
marlins have the lead-off man on on the
way to alfaro
ground ball left side de young gets to
it and
keeps it from getting into the outfield
but an infield single nonetheless for
jory alfaro marlins have two on
line drive caught
and the marlins get doubled up birdie
seemed to think he was back and he's
also not budged from second base and don
mattingly calls for the challenge and it
looks like that is going to get
overturned one would think at least by
that quick glance and they do overturn
that call so bertie's safe two on and
two out
first pitch swinging and a fly ball
right center who wants it it'll be dylan
carlson with the catch takes charge and
makes the play johann oviedo
no runs of out through sick two balls
two strikes
matt carpenter o for two here it comes
from sandy
and carpenter out towards center long
way back sierra makes the catch
going back and
diving to make the play for the first
out of the seventh inning sierra
with the speed
ouch you can hear that up here and that
caught him cleanly
it was a 97 mile an hour fastball that
just caught him so clean you can tell me
just in so much pain right here
wow
[Applause]
i didn't see that happening i did not
either did not either him staying in the
game
a fly ball out to center field sierra
coming in he'll make the play and sandy
is through seven brondon coming from
right field to second base and off the
bench lane thomas takes over in right
and they'll tend to sosa after being hit
by the pitch two outs
scoreless game
in the top of the eighth with the runner
at first the 2-2
swaying in a miss he struck him out
hellsly comes in and gets the strikeout
to end the top of the eighth sandy
alcatra has been up to the task today
for the marlins the 13th time this year
in which a marlins starting pitcher has
completed seven innings
up the middle birdie
turns throws and they get him at first
what a play by john birdie up the middle
to take a hit away from dylan carlson
and get sandy through eight innings for
the third time this year the o2
popped up
molina throws the mask near the screen
shading from the side makes the catch
a couple of spots near the screen where
jets out and he was right there
with the legs hitting up against it
[Applause]
in the air left field backing up o'neal
good work ryan housely sandy alcantara
you know it's waving to the home plate
umpire ryan ryan addington after that
last inning he must have been saying hey
man i'll see you in the ninth maybe so
because here he is
goldschmidt hits it up the middle and
the cargos will have the winning run
aboard
3-1 pitch
he walked him
the winning run will be in scoring
position for the cardinals molina is
over three today in the whole nothing in
two
molina pulls it fair
down into the left field corner
goldsmith will score
back-to-back games the cardinals walking
off it's a sweep of the marlins yachty
does it